few minutes ago that the most robust
sector of our economy the energy sector
has been withering thanks to the biden
administration but that's not the only
part of our economy that's in trouble
for generations america produced the
most and the best comedians in the world
this was the funniest country on earth
because it was a free country comedy
requires above all independence and
honesty you can't be reading talking
points from anybody you have to be
telling the truth about them that's the
whole point
and the second you start sucking up
you only humiliate yourself
well late on television they've been
sucking up to people in power for
several years now they haven't resigned
their jobs because they pay well
but they do continue to humiliate
themselves if you tuned in at any point
over the last year you saw things like
this
the cuomo brothers you and your brother
chris tied as the most desirable men in
new york
now as an older brother can you abide by
a tie
do you want to do anything right now to
push yourself over the top in terms of
desirableness you want to loosen the top
button you want to give us a smoldering
stair anything
i have to ask for a friend
they want to know i won't say her name
she wants to know what phase
of dating are you currently in
zero i'm at phase zero on dating
uh this is
there's no duration on phase zero yeah
there is no automatic time that you go
to phase one you could stay at phase
zero for months by the way i think new
york city will be fully reopened before
i get out of phase
zero on data
uh ugh it's so awful to watch
the fake over
your laughter
the stupid lines the endless sucking up
and the saddest part is some of these
guys
the people you just saw used to be
legitimately talented they were funny
but they gave it up in order to read the
script sad as hell to watch last night
the new version of the script told them
you'd better change your opinions on
andrew cuomo no more sucking up so
dutifully they did
well guys it was a big day here in new
york as andrew cuomo announced that he's
resigning as governor
during his remarks he said it was best
that he stepped aside and then every
woman in the room took two steps aside
during his announcement cuomo said that
he's stepping down in 14 days
i'm sorry but is this really a two-week
notice type of situation
beautiful day here in new york city
oh yeah 85 degrees 75 humidity
and this afternoon andrew cuomo resigned
don't let the door hit you on the butt
on the way out
but if it does that door should also
resign
do you think he comes home his wife says
good job good job you're really funny
ah no self-respect
at all
mark stein has self-respect and clarity
and honesty and above all perspective on
the world so he's hilarious by
definition he joins us now to assess
what happened to everybody else mark
stein great to see you
how sad did that make you watching that
i mean some of those guys were
legitimately talented at one point
at one point but uh i gotta say after
the those last clips you paid of uh
colbert and fallon that boy that uh say
what you like but that chromosexual
conversion therapy really works first i
mean they turned it around in 10 minutes
they were they were full-blown
homosexuals and now they're doing
crackerjack material
like uh what was that what was that line
that his writers wrote for him oh
cuomo said he was going to step aside
and then all the women uh took two steps
aside it's amazing to me they have like
37 writers on the writing staff and they
met for hours and they tested those
lines and that's the best they can come
now you have to see the problem from
fallon and colbert's point of view they
can't do anything genuinely funny
about the guy being a blood-soaked
butcher they can't do any sharp comedy
on that they can't do any comedy about
how pitiful it is uh that they're all uh
going on about how sexually they have
the hots for him and those mugs where
he's uh bare chested the chromosexual
coffee mugs
and they've fallen for an obvious uh an
obvious racket because the last three
governors of new york all democrats have
now all
resigned in one sexual scandal after
another you could do with your 37-man
writing team uh you could do some jokes
about how spitzer needed a uh a room at
the mayflower in washington dc and
that's like a thousand bucks a night and
then david patterson made do with the
days in on 94th street in manhattan and
that's only 130 bucks a night and then
this guy saves you the hotel bill all
together because he just gropes
everybody in the office but they can't
do anything even with the 37-man writing
team and i feel most sorry for
my dear commonwealth cousin trevor noah
from south africa whom i once saw at the
london palladium and who was marginally
less unfunny and what's interesting is
that 10 minutes after landing at jfk to
get his big job on the comedy channel
this guy who's got all kinds of
interesting perspectives south africa
via london all the rest of it he's
suddenly as instantly boring as all the
rest of them it's the death of comedy
it's no laughing matter
it's totally soviet they weren't very
funny either
marc stein great to see you tonight
thank you so much
thanks a lot tucker
so remember you heard of hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else